By direct order of President Andrés Manuel López Obrador,
red bows and 16 other cats living in the National Palace will be the first animals
in the history of Mexico that the federal government
will recognize as living fixed assets,
so they have guaranteed a budget for their food and care for life.
In an interview with Versal Adriana Román,
general director of the National Palace Preservation and Cultural Heritage,
she revealed that due to this recognition,
the 19 cats living in the historic enclosure were given a chip to monitor
them and provide them with adequate care.
"It was in August of last year when the National Palace's conservation directorate
was able to inventory the kittens to feed them vaccines and protect them.
This is the first government that pays attention to the area,
so we call on the rest of the government and
private institutions to do the same,
" Adriana said.